have you ever bought a nice hoodie
before okay have you ever bought a piece
overpriced based on what have you ever
touched it have you ever looked at it do
you know anything about it we work with
some of the best manufacturers in the
world the same manufacturers that make
stuff like Palace Supreme and all the
top brands they actually charge more for
the same type of product that's made in
the same Factory but because we know
that we don't want to mark it up too
much on our customer great and so what
I'll do is I'll buy one of these hoodies
I'll buy one of your hoodies I'll have
it shipped here and I'll check it out
and then I'll DM you I'll let you know
what I think about it can you buy one of
Ethan Klein's hoodies can I please ask
you one thing who's a better salesman me
or you what do you mean I don't know why
you're asking me this question because I
just [__] sold your ass a hoodie
[__]
[Music]
you should
set within my